en el vídeo pasado comenzamos con la
matriz a que era una matriz de dos por
tres la matriz 2 menos 13 426 y
calculamos su espacio columna que es
simplemente el espacio vectorial
generado por las columnas de a que es un
sub espacio de r2 tengo dos entradas en
cada columna así que vimos que este era
generado por el vector 2 menos 4
checamos que las otras dos columnas son
múltiplos escalares de la primera
también calculamos el espacio nulo de la
matriz
es decir el sub espacio de r3 que está
formado por los vectores x tales que a
por el vector x nos daba el vector 0 en
r2 y vimos que ese sub espacio era
generado por estos dos vectores después
nos movimos al ha transpuesto y
encontramos el espacio nulo de la trans
puesta que también dijimos que se
llamaba el espacio nulo izquierdo de la
matriz original vimos que éste era
generado por el vector 2 1
y finalmente calculamos el espacio de
las columnas de a transpuesta el espacio
columna de a transpuesta que viene a ser
lo mismo que el sub espacio generado por
los renglones de a y vimos que este era
el sub espacio generado por el vector
2 - 1 - 3 que si se fijan es simplemente
el primer renglón de lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es visualizar estas cosas
geométricamente bien pues comencemos con
lo siguiente lo voy a escribir aquí para
tener el espacio de abajo libre así que
consideren la siguiente transformación
es una transformación que x al vector x
lo manda en la matriz a multiplicada por
el vector x muy bien esta transformación
ya sabemos que es una transformación
lineal pero de dónde a dónde va pues
pues va de algún rn a algún
r m la matriz a es una matriz de 2 x 3
eso quiere decir que para que el
producto matriz vector esté bien
definido la tengo que multiplicar por
vectores que tengan 3 entradas así que
te va de r3
r3 a donde pues una matriz de dos por
tres multiplicada por un vector que lo
puedo pensar como una matriz de tres por
uno es lo mismo que una matriz de dos
por uno que puedo pensar como un vector
en r2 así que te es una transformación
lineal de r3 en r2 ok entonces veamos
quién es mi dominio
dominio
obviamente estoy hablando de la
transformación de pues mi dominio como
decía es r3 tienes mico dominio co
dominio
mikko dominio simplemente a donde llegó
y llegó a r2
r2
ok entonces sí quiero graficar estas
cosas vamos a primero averiguar qué
subespacios de estos son sub espacios
qué les parece empecemos con r2 ok si
empiezo con r2 entonces tengo que mi
espacio columna de la matriz a está
contenido en r2 si se fijan simplemente
está generado por un vector de re 2 otro
modo de pensar en esto es donde están
las columnas de a pues cada columna como
decía tiene dos entradas así que está en
r2 y también si nos fijamos el espacio
nulo de a transpuesta el espacio nulo de
a transpuesta que recuerden le llamamos
el espacio no lo izquierdo de a también
está contenido en r2 es un sub espacio
de r2
ambos son y sub espacios de herreros así
que viene vamos a graficar esto
y bueno
veamos
y me pongo mis ejes coordinados esto no
va a ser muy exacto pero ojalá puedan
darse una idea geométrica y agarrar un
poco de intuición al respecto
ok ahí están mis ejes algo chicos
y asimétrico esperando importa ok quien
es el espacio columna de a pues es el
sub espacio vectorial generado por este
vector el vector 2 menos 4 a ver
pongamos el vector 2 menos 4 así que 1 2
y luego bajo 4 1 2 3 4
está por aquí así que el vector dos
menos cuatro se ve bueno se ve algo así
ok ahora quién es el sub espacio que
genera pues recuerden que el sub espacio
consiste en todas las combinaciones
lineales en este caso simplemente son
todos los múltiplos de este vector todos
los múltiplos de este vector que serían
una línea recta en r2
así que es esto de aquí
únicamente
esto es una representación gráfica del
espacio columna de a
el espacio columna de a
que también lo podría pensar de hecho
como el espacio fila
es lo mismo que el espacio a fila
de a transpuesta tiene sentido no porque
las las filas los renglones de atrás
puestas son simplemente las columnas de
a así que es esto de aquí ahora bien
tienes
tiene es el espacio nulo de a
transpuesta pues el espacio nulo de a
transpuesta está generado por el vector
21 así que dos y subo uno vamos a decir
que más o menos por ahí
ese sería el vector 21 y genera un sub
espacio
genera un sub espacio que son todos los
múltiplos escalares de este vector y eso
es una línea recta de nuevo es una línea
recta
en r2 se ve algo así así que esto de
aquí sería la representación gráfica del
espacio nulo de a transpuesta que
habíamos dicho esto es lo mismo que el
espacio nulo izquierdo de a espacio nulo
izquierdo
izquierdo de a muy bien y si se fijan
aquí parece que pasa algo extraño no
parece que este ángulo es de 90 grados
parece que estos dos espacios son
ortogonales y vamos a checar eso vamos a
checar precisamente eso supongan se
pongan que ustedes tienen un primer
vector de uno de uno que pertenece a el
espacio columna de a entonces qué forma
tiene de uno pues si está en el espacio
columna de a y el espacio columna de a
está generado por el vector dos menos
cuatro entonces
v 1 es igual a alguna constante c 1 por
el vector
2 - 42 menos 4 ok y supongan también que
tengo algún vector en el espacio nulo
izquierdo de a en el espacio nulo de la
trans puesta entonces de 2
v2 está en el espacio nulo izquierdo de
a o lo que es lo mismo el espacio nulo
la transporta que yo sé que es generada
por el vector 21 entonces b 2
es igual a debajo
c2 alguna constante 0 2 por el vector
por el vector
ok entonces si yo tomo a b1 y le hago
producto punto o producto interior con b
2 que resulta pues sería lo mismo que
hacer se uno por el vector dos menos
cuatro producto punto
producto punto c 2 por el vector 2 1
ok pero nosotros sabemos de las
propiedades del producto punto producto
interior que esto es lo mismo que se uno
por c 2
multiplicando el producto punto de 2 - 4
con 2 1
los escalares salen del producto pero
esto con todo esto sería 1 x 2 x 2 x 2
que es 4 más menos 4 x 1 que sería menos
44 más menos 4 o 4 menos 4 que pues
estoy aquí es cero
este último cacho digamos es cero
entonces segundo por ser dos por cero
pues es cero así que estos dos vectores
son ortogonales y de hecho vamos a ver
en algún otro vídeo que esto siempre
pasa el espacio columna de a siempre es
ortogonal al espacio nulo izquierdo de a
y nos de hecho no es tan difícil
probarlo creo que sería un buen
ejercicio que lo intentarán probar a
partir de las definiciones que tenemos
de producto de matrices pero bueno
pasemos a r3
ok entonces comencemos con el espacio
nulo de a que es el generado por estos
dos vectores dibujarlo en r3 es un poco
más complicado de hecho es bastante más
complicado hacerlo a escala así que lo
voy a hacer de un modo muy general es un
sub espacio generado por dos vectores en
r3 pero qué es eso pues eso es
sencillamente un plano así que déjenme
yo tratar de dibujar un plano
está muy feo lo sé pero por favor usen
su imaginación así que esto de aquí esto
de aquí
es el espacio nulo de a ok y algo que
quizás no resulte evidente es que este
vector es ortogonal a cualquiera de
estos dos vectores de hecho vamos a
checar eso qué pasa si tomo a este
vector al vector
2 - 13 2 - 1 3
hago producto punto producto interior
con el vector primero con el un medio 10
un medio 10
pues por definición esa es la suma del
producto entrada entrada así que dos por
un medio es uno más menos uno por uno
que sería menos uno más tres por cero
que sería cero cuánto me da esto pues es
cero así que este vector es ortogonal el
primero vamos a checar ahora
qué
2 - 13 2 - 1 3
2 - 13 es ortogonal a
es ortogonal a tres medios 0 1
de nuevo cuánto es esto dos por tres
medios es sencillamente 3
menos 1 por 0 es 0
3 por 1 a perdón aquí me como un signo
que es menos 36 y no me hubiera
funcionado observen es menos 3 hecho
aquí también me lo comí aguas hay que
tener cuidado con los signos ok menos
tres por uno es bueno menos uno por cero
es más 0 - 3 por 1 es menos 3
30 - 30 así que este vector también es
ortogonal al segundo y de hecho
de hecho lo puede hacer en general
esto va a ser un poco enredado pero
bueno vamos a suponer que tengo un
vector b 1 que está en el espacio nulo
de a entonces yo sé que es una
combinación de
es una combinación lineal de este vector
y este vector
así que ve uno
es igual a digamos a por un medio 10
más ve por
tres medios 0 1
ok y vamos a decir que tengo un b2
un b2 que pertenece a quien pues al
espacio columna de a transpuesta o lo
que es lo mismo el espacio de renglones
de a entonces b 2
v2 qué forma va a tener pues es algún
múltiple escalar de este vector
recuerden que el espacio columna de a
transpuesta está generado exclusivamente
por este vector así que de 2 va a ser de
la forma de algún escalar d por el
vector por el vector 2 - 1 - 3 recuerden
los signos tienen que estar bien si no
todo se va a arruinar ok ya que tengo
esto cuánto vale que usamos azul
cuanto vale de un producto punto con v2
pues esto es lo mismo que de 1era a x
un medio 10
más de por
tres medios 0 1
y esto le voy a tomar producto puntocom
de por el escalar de por el vector 2 - 1
- 3
ok y cuánto es esto
pues yo sé que el producto punto es
distributivo sobre la suma de hecho el
producto punto tiene una propiedad muy
fuerte que se llama be linealidad pero
no quiero hablar de eso ahorita así que
bueno si distribuyo esto sobre la suma
de 1 por b 2x
voy a usar el mismo color es lo mismo
que aporte a x de x
un medio 10 producto punto con
2 - 1 - 3
que sería este caso por esto más ahora
este caso por esto
depor de x
tres medios 01 producto punto com
2 - 1 - 3
ok y cuánto es esto pues
esto de aquí es cero eso ya lo sabíamos
luego teníamos algo de aquí está este
cacho de cero y este cacho también es
cero
eso es de acá abajo así que todo esto es
0 0 es cero así que cualquier vector en
el espacio de el espacio fila de a o el
espacio columnas de a transpuesta es
ortogonal a cualquier vector en el
espacio nulo de a eso es muy bonito así
que el espacio el espacio columna de a
transpuesta el espacio fila de a es en
realidad una línea en r3 que es
ortogonal a este plano y continúa tras
ok recuerdo en dos cosas recuerden que
este plano se extiende en todas
direcciones
y no termina y si digamos aquí pongo los
vectores que generando mi plano que son
estos dos vamos a decir que uno es
ese vector de allí y el otro es ese
vector de allí recuerden este no es un
dibujo escala
entonces cualquier vector digamos que el
que genera al espacio columna de a
transpuesta es este de aquí entonces
cualquier vector en
el espacio columna de a transpuesta que
de hecho déjenme lo escribo así esto es
lo mismo que el espacio
fila
de a
eso es lo mismo que el espacio columna
de a transpuesta
y cualquier vector de aquí es ortogonal
a cualquier vector de el espacio nulo de
a
y de hecho déjenme también escribo esto
casi no tengo espacio así que perdonen
que voy a amontonar todo pero el espacio
no lo deja también lo puedo pensar como
el espacio nulo
nulo izquierdo
sobre viera izquierdo de jan o de a sino
de a transpuesta estas definiciones son
simétricas si el espacio nulo de a
perdón el espacio nulo de a transpuesta
es igual al espacio nulo izquierdo de a
entonces el espacio no lo es el espacio
nulo izquierdo de a transpuesta
pero bueno noten que los vectores que
están en el espacio fila de a siempre
son ortogonales a los vectores que están
en el espacio nulo de a y los los
vectores que son están en el espacio
nulo de atrás pues estás siempre son
ortogonales a los vectores que están en
el espacio fila de a transpuesta de
hecho de hecho no sólo son ortogonales
son todos los vectores que son
ortogonales eso se dice que el espacio
fila de a es el complemento ortogonal al
espacio nulo de a es algo más fuerte y
estas dos cosas son en realidad muy
bonitas lo probaré en el siguiente vídeo